you had a great quote from one of your
pre-draft press conferences about the
receiver position and
you said that the receivers on the team
are insulted by the perception that the
receivers aren't very good and you're
personally insulted by it and it was
great we played it on one of our shows
we reacted to it and then you drafted
two receivers one in round one and
running one in round four how do we
reconcile what you said about the
receivers before the draft with the fact
that you drafted two more
well that was before the draft
is like anybody that tries to read too
much into what people say before the
draft you know they're acting foolish
and you know we're trying to win
everything we do is based on does this
help our club win
does this put us in the best position to
win so yeah as you know mike you write
about it all the time there's a lot of
foolishness being said before the draft
anonymous scouts and things like that we
don't really play that game but for me
to stand up there and talk about how
we're going to build the team
you know before the draft is probably
not the smartest thing in the world so
what i said really in my intentions was
that i believe our receivers do
want to be the best they do care about
that and we believe in those guys
um we're still going to build the very
best team we can build at any point now
before the season during training camp
after the season whatever that might be
there's gamesmanship involved and
there's a strategy involved and for me
to go up there and say we're going to
draft a receiver in the first round that
would be foolish and everybody should
understand that um on the other hand i
do believe in our receivers uh you know
very strongly i do believe in those guys
i do believe
in hollywood brown miles boyce and devon
durenay james crochet samuel watkins
we do believe in those guys uh we also
believe in bateman we also believe in in
teal and wallace as well and we think
we've really you know strengthened that
class of players and that's going to
make us a better offense
[Music]
eric decosta from pft pm i love it when
they admit that
this stuff they say before the draft is
bs because by the time we get to next
year's draft and the run up to it we
will have forgotten that and they're
going to say what they say it gets
reported it gets repeated and some of
it's true maybe coincidentally but yeah
no one is going to come out and say man
we really need receivers in this draft
we are going to go heavy
for receivers we're really not happy
with the guys we have we can't get free
agents to come here and play in a
run-based offense yeah we're going after
receivers so that's what that's what
they got to do but it's just refreshing
that someone will admit that peter
but what exactly did eric dicosta say
before the draft
he said essentially
i am ticked off at everybody ripping our
receivers
we like our receivers and he used
stronger language than that
but that's in essence what he said
and i believe that he really does like
devin duvernay now does he think that
devin duvernay is a number one receiver
probably not you know does he think that
hollywood brown
has the stuff to stay on the field for
58 snaps a game probably not
you know so but
i i do not think that what he said
before the draft
necessarily means that they're not
taking any receivers high in this draft
well but i think when you come out and
say it's insulting to suggest we don't
have good receivers they're insulted by
it yeah i'm insulted by it the
implication is we're sufficiently
pleased with them not you know they've
got a good personality but we're pleased
with their
performance that we don't feel as
compelled to upgrade the position as
outsiders may think so it would tend to
throw that is not at all what i took
from what he said though
i did not take that at all mike what i
took is that
stay off our receivers backs you know i
i i got i got the backs of my guys you
know i am pro
devin duvernay i love miles boykin i
love these guys now you can say that and
then you can still draft rashad bateman
27th overall those are not mutually
exclusive things
those are standing up for the guys on
your team and then
fixing a part of your team that you
believe
could be better and i think that's what
this is about i and i understand that
everybody said whoa look at what decosta
said and all that but honestly i think
most gm's would say that before the
draft about a position
on their roster that's under attack from
outsiders
well
that's probably just being a good
manager but at the same time
management has found some new employees
both in round one and in round four who
could supplant individuals that they
think are very nice people and they like
very much and would be good enough
but there are better options and it gets
back to what we're talking about with
the union it's a zero-sum game there's
only so many jobs you have opportunities
to stand out or not stand out and the
off season program is part of that
opportunity so when bateman and wallace
enter the fray assuming they show up for
the offseason program they get a chance
to catch the eye of decosta and john
harbaugh and everyone else who's
monitoring to determine who are the ones
that they should make not just part of
the roster but put on the field
in the two and three and four receiver
packages
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports